Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Nr. 10 und diesmal vom Chaos Communication Congress mit einer Sonderausgabe. Mit mir ist Régine Débatty, die unter anderem auch einen Vortrag heute auf dem Chaos Communication Congress gehalten hat über Hightech und Media Art. Und ein Novum auf diesem Kanal. Wir machen das Interview auf Englisch, denn Régine kommt aus Belgien. Okay, so, hallo Régine, are you there? I'm a bit confused. You are living in Italy?
Yeah, I'm in Belgium and I'm living in Italy now.
So why are you doing this? I mean, why did you move to Italy?
And I had this huge expectation about Italy, so I've been very disappointed. You will?
Okay, so, but you didn't mention art. I mean, isn't art also a reason to go to Italy?
Yeah, ancient art, if you like old stones. Italy is great. But as I'm more interested in media art, I think Berlin is a much better place for me because of course there is media art in Italy, but it's not as exciting as here.
Okay, so you are already pointing me to what I have to explain. You are running a weblog, a quite popular weblog, if I may say that, on the internet, which is called We Make Money Not Art. I don't know when I really stumbled upon this weblog quite a while ago, but since then I noticed that first I was getting new information that nobody else was blogging about, and then I got the same information because everybody was more or less getting it from you. When did you start that weblog? Okay, so it's pretty new still, but it's already very active.
I just left my job. I decided that blogging would be my job, so I do it full-time. I take it as a work, and it's a very pleasant work. It's really my passion. So I finish at 11 o'clock in the morning, but most of the time it's not easy. So I'm still in front of my computer at 10 o'clock in the evening. And no, it's really work. Also because of my blog, I get invited to conference. But I go to conference, I try to attend, and I try to talk and listen to the other speakers. And then I go back to my hotel room or to an internet café and start blogging. And if I have to take the plane at 7 o'clock, I will be up at 4 o'clock because I want to blog a little bit. And I know that if I have readers, it's also because they know that every day they can come to my blog and they will find something new. Yeah, it's not as much as boing boing, but yeah, I think it's amazing. I'm first impressed by that. And so we met that guy who was working for a communication company, and he was at the time quite obsessed with mobile phones. And he made some artistic applications with mobile phones, and he showed it in galleries outside of Italy. And yeah, he's both heard about it, and he thought, wow, that's interesting. And he managed to sell this artistic application to one of the main mobile phone operators in Italy. So we thought, oh, that's great. So we have someone who's kind of an amateur, half an amateur, half an artist, and half... He's also a hacker. And here's the industry on the other hand, and both of them meet, because he has met something with that technology. So we thought maybe we should investigate the field. We wanted to have a project, we didn't know exactly what kind of project, but we wanted to investigate how artists, hackers and amateurs are using or misusing technology and see if somehow they could meet or collaborate with people who are selling and manufacturing this technology. And so we thought before launching a project, maybe we should try to document it and try to see what's happened. And we thought the best way to document it would be to write a blog. So there were four people in the beginning, but the others were not interested in the blog at all, so it just ended up. Yeah, more or less, yeah. I was alone and then I have two collaborators, let's pretend two people who are collaborating and writing a post each week or more, if they feel like that, if they have time. There's a brilliant guy from Japan who's called Konomi Sinishi, who's a researcher in the University of Colorado and has worked in Tokyo and also for the Fraunhofer Institute. He's a specialist of RFID, but he's quite interested in media arts, so he's covering the new media arts scene in Japan. I have someone from Berlin, who's Sascha Poflepp, who's studying at the UDK in Berlin.
Universität der Kunst. So it's starting to become a community blog in a way, but you're the main contributor still, I think. So we haven't really touched on... So why do you make money not art? Does it mean you do not consider your work to be art? Is it just news?
Yeah, I don't think I'm doing art. I meet many students and they ask questions to me.
It's definitely a resource for finding cool stuff. And if you don't know the weblog, I can really recommend checking it out at wemakemoneynotart.com with the dashes in between. So where does the money come from?
But it seems that my readers are not click monkeys and many, many of them read me through RSS feeds so they don't even see the adverts. For example, the blog is called We Make Money Not Art.
I think this is typical for many people who are more or less building their private business around their blog or around their media outlet, whatever it is, also podcasting, more or less following the same path. And I think that it's a very good way and it's a good mix. Because on the one hand you're really offering a service to people who are interested and really can't follow that much. I have been very impressed many, many times how much good stuff there is on the Internet. Usually if you just browse around, you don't really find it. It's very important to find the right channel, the right source for people filtering out the unnecessary things and really finding the pearls on the net. So we talk quite a lot about how this works and how you're working, but not so much about what it's all about. So can I say it's about media art?
Yeah, it should be about media art or artists are using technology, but I'm also writing about things I like. I write a lot about biotechnology or interaction design or vintage stuff. It depends on my mood, but yeah, I think it's about new media art. But I got a nomination recently for best medical blog.
Okay, just too many awards out there on the Internet. Okay, wir kommen wieder zurück zu Régine. Heute hast du gerade einen Sitz im Chaos-Kommunikation-Kongress hier in Berlin. Der Titel war High-Tech Media Art.
New Media Art of the Threaded Track. Ich werde keine Definition geben, ich werde nur auf deine letzte Frage herunterfallen, die ist, wie ich sie sehe. Und das war's. Und ja, dieses Ort ist sauber und luminös und es gibt gute Schauspieler. Heute war ich einfach in der Vorstellung eines sehr offen-mindeden und sehr berühmten Menschen. Ich hatte Kommentare und alles war sehr pertinent.
Natürlich gibt es viele Varianten, und es ist völlig unmöglich, ein einziges Individual zu definieren, nur indem man ihm den Tank anbricht, wie ein Hacker, aber in generell ist diese Ökonomie die wichtigste Sache. Wenn du das sagst, gibt es einen interessanten Essay, der von einem Mann, Paul Graham, sehr populär ist, er ist Programmer, auch ein sehr erfolgreicher Programmer, und er hat einen Essay geschrieben, er hat ein großes Buch geschrieben, aber dieser kleine Teil ist nur ein Teil davon, er nennt es Hackers and Painters, er vergleichet Hackers und Painters, und zeigt, dass er viel mehr Beziehungen zwischen einem Painter und einem Hacker sieht, als andere Wissenschaftler, dass Hacking im Allgemeinen nicht eine wissenschaftliche Beziehung, sondern eher die gleiche Beziehung, wie ein Painter, wenn er eine Bilder schreibt, hier eine Farbe verkleidet, aber es korrekt, es sieht, es beobachtet, und es wird immer im Prozess geregelt. Was ist der Beziehung zwischen dem Art-Szene und dem Hacker-Szene? Oder sind Artisten und Hacker generell?
Ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass es mehr Punkte in den Kommunen gibt zwischen Hacker und New Media Artist, als zwischen New Media Artist und Contemporary Artist. Ich habe eine Interview gemacht und sie sagten, oh, in deinem Werk ist ein Artist. Ich sagte, nein, nein, ich bin kein Artist. Es gibt viele Punkte in der Kommunikation. Aber während Hackerinnen und Hackern die Technologie funktioniert, haben die Künstler eine andere Perspektive. Sie wollen die Technologie mehr oder weniger nur um ihre Punkte zu bekommen. Aber sie machen keine perfekten Technologien, die für andere funktionieren.
Du bist ein Medienartist, weil du eine TV oder ein elektronisches Gerät benutzt hast, für seltsame Gründe. Es ist mehr, etwas zu beitragen, etwas zu verbreiten. Aber ich habe auch gesehen, besonders auf deiner Webseite, einige Projekte in der letzten Zeit, die dieses Bild wirklich verändern.
Ich denke, ich bin nicht für lange in der neuen Medienart interessiert. Was ich heute aus der Konferenz gesehen habe, ist, dass sie natürlich treffen sollten. Ich habe mit vielen Hacker gesprochen und sie sagten, dass sie wissen, wie Dinge funktionieren. Heute zeigen wir ihnen die Serie von Künstlern, die Künstler organisieren, die Menschen wie die Straßenmänner und sagen, komm, wir zeigen dir, wie man einen Key-Holder macht, der auf jeden Fall vor einem RFID-Künstler leitet. Oder sie helfen, Menschen mit Künstlern zu machen, oder sie zeigen ihnen, wie sie cool und lustige Dinge machen können, mit der Technologie, die sie von teuren Künstlern bekommen haben.
Viele Menschen haben in der Gegend ein bestimmtes Verständnis für Technologie in der Gegend, besonders Computer, gesehen, dass sie aus Proportionen sind, nicht wirklich mit Art ausgestattet sind. Es ist wie eine Nummern-Kranzer-Maschine. Es gibt diese bekannten Hacker-Ethiken, diese 10 goldenen Regeln. Es ist aus dem Buch Hacker Heroes of the Computer Revolution von Steven Levy. Er hat eine Hacker-Szene von den 60er-Jahren beobachtet. Als die Hackerinnen und Hacker die Maschinen angenommen und versucht haben, mit ihnen zu arbeiten und Dinge zu kreieren, fokussieren sie sich wirklich auf schönen Dinge, wie die ersten Computer-Games und auch nur lustige Dinge. Das ist auch das Grund, warum das Hauptzentrale Zimmer im Chaos-Kommunikationskongress die Art und Schöne-Area genannt wurde. Es war immer mein Verständnis, dass Hacking selbst Kunst ist. Und auf der anderen Seite würde ich einen Künstler als Hacking auch als Prozess für sie denken.
Sie haben eine andere Meinung, weil sie aus anderen Hintergründen kommen. Ich habe also ein Problem mit der Definition von neuen Medienartistinnen.
Also wir sind wieder hier mit Régine Débatty, von We Make Money Not Art. Und wir haben auch gerade über die Art, wie Artisten und Hacker aussehen oder nicht. Ein Punkt, der in meinem Kopf kommt, ist, dass viele Artisten, die ich kenn, einen sehr versperrten Weg haben, ihre eigenen Ideen zu handeln. Viele Leute werden von anderen Menschen erinnert, und nennen sie ihre Ideen. Ich hatte diese Idee vorher. Ich bin in das Gefühl, als wir das Blinken-Lights-Projekt gemacht haben. Ich hatte diese Idee vorher. Es gibt ein paar Projekte, die vorher mit uns waren, die das selbe haben und die selbe Idee verfolgen. Eines Tages hat mir ein Journalist gesagt, dass es den Turner-Prize in England. Wir hatten 144 von denen. Er fragte mich, ob ich als Künstler nicht richtig erinnere, was er gesagt hat.
Für mich ist Blickenline ein Stück Kunst.
Ich denke, es gibt keine Art, als eine originelle Idee zu sein. Denn was in meinem Geist kommt, werden sicher Tausende von Leuten schon so etwas gehabt haben. Wahrscheinlich haben sie nichts gemacht. Vielleicht kommt ein anderer Arschloch drei Jahre später und versucht, einen Patent auf dem Bild zu machen. Aber das bedeutet nicht, dass ich eine schlechte Art für Künstler habe. Wir teilen unsere Software. Weil sie die original Idee einfach aufnehmen, nehmen sie die Dokumentation und auch die Kode. Nicht nur die Kode, sie schreiben auch ihre eigene Kode. Jetzt ist es in einer Art noch lebendig, was ich auch sehr gewünscht finde.
Ein Freund in Italien macht eine Kunstinstallation. Eine seiner großen Gefühle ist, dass er von China kopiert wird. Und es ist immer noch eine Exzellentie. Aber wir haben uns auf das Thema der Konferenz, die private Investigation, befasst. Wir haben uns auf zwei Technologien befasst, einer war RFID und der andere auf die Surveillance Technologien, mehr CCTV-Kameras. Unsere Künstler haben es benutzt und versuchen, eine neue Werte zu diesen Technologien zu geben. Wir haben mit dem RFID angefangen, die zeigen, dass einige Künstler die dunkle Seite der Technologie zeigen. Sie zeigen eine Video über die dunkle Seite des RFID. Sie gaben einen Kugelkuchen zu jedem, der ihn akzeptierte, und sie haben ihn von dem Kugelkuchen eingeführt und ihn dann in ihren lokalen Supermarkt, dem Walmart, in den Supermarkt, den der universalen Akzeptanz des RFID-Taktes auf den Markt gelegt hat. Sie haben ihn in den Supermarkt eingeführt, hofften, dass er ins Database des Walmarten verbreiten würde. Dann haben wir andere Projekte gezeigt, die RFID benutzen, und die zeigen, dass RFID nur eine Technologie ist. Eine von ihnen ist mein Lieblingsprojekt, es heißt Peripheral Needs. Es ist für Menschen mit obsessiven, kompulsiven Verbrechen. Sie sind auf dem Bus und fragen sich, ob sie die Lichtung oder den Ofen oder was auch immer ausgeschaltet haben. Sie gehen auf dem Bus zurück nach Hause, um zu schauen, ob alles ausgeschaltet ist. Oder sie wachen auf in der Mitte der Nacht und gehen nach unten, um zu sehen, ob der Toaster gewechselt ist. Es funktioniert so, dass auf jeder elektrischen Applianz ein Velcro ist und einen RFID-Tag hat. Unterhalb der elektrischen Applianz ist ein Reader. Du nimmst den Velcro und deaktivierst den elektrischen Applianz. Du musst dann auf deinen Backpack schauen, und du siehst, dass der Ofen-Switch da ist.
Auch bei der Hackasy ist das ein sehr kompliziertes Thema. Auf der einen Seite ist es nur Technologie. Unser genialer Standpunkt auf Technologie ist, dass es immer eine Chance und immer ein Risiko ist. Es ist sehr schwierig, wenn man weiß, dass eine bestimmte Technologie wirklich riskiert ist, obwohl es Chancen gibt, eine positive Image zu bekommen, insbesondere bei den Surveillance-Kameras. Ich denke, sie könnten die Ruhe aufreißen.
TROYA bedeutet Temporal Residenz Intelligenz Agent. Innerhalb des Stages sind interaktive Installationen, die Dinge über Surveillance-Technologie erklären. Ich denke, dass ihre Rolle wichtig ist, so dass sie etwas verhindern, etwas sehr leicht zu verstehen und zu erinnern, etwas sehr physisch, das die Menschen der Straße verstehen können. Es ist ein Schild der CCTV-Kameras der Stadt, ich glaube, das war in New York. Wenn du von Punkt 1 bis Punkt B gehen willst, kannst du dein Programm auf der PDA checken und es wird dir erklären, welchen Weg du nehmen sollst, um unter den Augen der Surveillance-Kamera weniger möglich zu sein. Und du siehst, es wurde erklärt, dass ein Freund von ihm versucht, etwas ähnliches in London zu machen, aber er hat es in einer besonderen Nachbarschaft gemacht, die Hackney war.
Das ist ein Problem. Ich denke, es geht um Angst.
Und die Information ist in einem Weg vorgesehen.
Vielen Dank für das Einladen in unser Podcast-Studio. Danke für deinen Sitz, das Künstler-Kommunikation-Kongress. Das Video wird bald online sein. Ich kann nicht sagen, wann, aber die Leute arbeiten daran. Wir werden die Links auf unserer Webseite events.ccc.de geben. Das ist ein Blog, das auf den 22. Chaos-Kommunikation-Kongress beruht. Dezember hier in Berlin. Wenn du den Work of Régine checken willst, ist es das Web-Blog wemakemoneynotart.com.